all right turning now to our next guest
comedian Hannah Gatsby Gatsby became a
household name after the release of
their groundbreaking comedy special
Nanette that was back in 2018 that
Netflix special earned them a Peabody
Award and a prime time Emmy Award now
they're back with their third Netflix
special called Hannah Gatsby something
special in it they discussed getting
married living with autism and also
share some pretty funny family stories
take a look
I remember when my mum got a first ever
pair of false teeth it was a very
unsettling time of my life I was a
teenager and when she got them
they were too big
right and for whatever reason she just
didn't get them tightened up for a good
couple of years
so they just rattled around so whenever
she became animated
the top racket dropped down and just
completely transform her face
angry
they break out in the
big smile
[Applause]
she'd be like well you can leave home if
you like you're not welcome here
and I guess he joins us now good morning
Hannah that was hilarious I I watched
this special this past weekend could not
stop laughing and you know I want to ask
you this uh it's a different tone than
your previous specials you said that
you've dragged audiences through all
your stuff as you put it uh for many
years now and this is the payoff
yeah you know I played the long game you
get it yeah
um so I just uh I wanted to show like
Nanette my first special on Netflix was
it was a was hard talking about a bit of
trauma I want to say that there's a
another side of it
um a surprise people and you know
sometimes I feel like in today's climate
there's a lot of anti-lgbtq sentiment in
the world and I feel like I'd like to
create a show where my people just have
a nice time so this was a romantic
comedy well yeah yeah and you were
saying that and and kind of putting a
little message out to the world this
also relates to your own love story and
tell us a little bit about this wedding
cake that oh god well we had trouble
there's a lot of decisions I don't know
if you've heard of marriage but it is a
lot of positions involved and we got
decision fatigue very quickly because
neither of us think about and thought
about weddings and then we came up with
an idea of just like what do you want
and instead of a list it's the first
thing you thought so where do you want
to where should we get marriage like
under that tree and then what sort of
cake would you like and I said I want a
shark cake so then for your wedding cake
yes with a shark and we got a Christian
Baker to make it so that
they didn't know it was a wedding cake
but we did we feel very
clever it's a feel-good special but you
don't specify who's gonna feel good no
no Christian bakers will feel terrible
but they're artists you know now you
mentioned um rhetoric um surrounding the
lgbtq plus community and I remember when
Dave Chappelle had some jokes about the
trans Community you came out and spoke
uh to Netflix and the CEO of Netflix and
wanted to make sure that voices were
heard so much so you signed the
multi-year deal with them why was it
important for you to make that statement
and then say I want to change the
perspective as a stand-up comedian well
you know I'm a big believer in freedom
of speech so you know you use speech to
say something else as a as opposed to
circling what's already being said sort
of change the conversation you know I
wanted to just yes help lift up newer
comedians
um it's you know getting that that lift
out of up into a next level of Comedy is
quite difficult so I you know I want to
retire soon I'm getting old
retire soon what oh I don't know how you
get up every day you're at the top of
your game right now that's when you
leave you leave the morning more I've
heard well you also don't shy away from
controversial topics in any kind of way
I probably should though I don't know I
feel like the region says it's okay just
keep going but let me ask you this so uh
you're also in town right now in New
York because you have a pretty special
exhibit that's opening uh later this
week and it's about Pablo Picasso who
you've railed against in the past so now
you're co-career curating an exhibit
dedicated to him tell us about that yeah
well it's his 50th anniversary of his
death so I think that's worth
celebrating
um but the Picasso Museum in Paris is
you know coordinated with museums all
around the world to celebrate his his
Legacy
um and so the Brooklyn Museum reached
out to me and said do you want to
complicate that Legacy with us and I
said I sure would so it's opening end of
this week uh and we're it's a feminist
perspective so we're including a lot of
work works by feminists sort of you know
minimize him
[Music]
he will survive I don't feel like
Picasso's gonna he's here anytime soon
he's dead so his feelings can't
technically be hurt so I'm not terribly
sad for him but uh I just wanted to
shake the conversation up a little bit
uh in the list of top three questions
comedians hate the most and find
annoying uh this next one's probably on
there I'm glad you're asking us so I'm
going with it yeah what is the secret to
making people laugh oh oh not this yeah
no I know early mornings this is the
death of Comedy
um I mean we like to think we're pretty
funny you are but for my recipe my
recipe that requires people to be drunk
um I'm sure there's a few people
um
some of our viewers are just waking up
on the couch from the night before so
where do you think I came from
um uh it's a it's a weird I don't know
all the time why people laugh at me
um but I just keep repeating it
that's that's you wait when people laugh
you work out why they laughed and then
keep doing it sometimes your jokes are
not even jokes they're just beautiful
and and phrases that make you laugh for
days on it like a perineum of time it's
not the destination but it's kind of fun
to be there I feel that way about this
interview
this interview is not the destination
this is you know the job goes on from
here we're not going to unpack this no
let's leave it there
let's just have a very happy memory yeah
yeah this was pleasant and this was
too Nancy
thank you very much for joining us and
you can watch Hannah catch me something
special now on Netflix